hey we're that younger and we are
playing oh yeah
[Music]
that's wise fine that foster cuz it's
Jimmy Caan [ __ ] Debbie's like no no I
might know my lines on the first take
but I wouldn't say I would nail it I'm
gonna take I feel like it'll be like six
hours on me and then we turn around that
sounds like and a psycho boom and we're
done and I was like oh I've had some
pretty stellar mom yeah I wanna write
this I think I know a lot of take as
long as I've been able to like work on
my dialogue with I'm the one with kids
so I don't always have that dialogue
yeah listen I was trained by Disney I'm
pretty prepared okay do we have a lot
[Laughter]
yeah not this not this
I always forget to do that I'm not on it
absolutely at all she gonna do it any no
yeah you know like this tag I send
Hillary dog dogs every day multiple and
you've sent me a lot of myself I do have
you yeah maybe enough definitely the
wand I think you yeah multiple diamonds
oh the best one was the one that would
they like slowed down my speech and they
were like me on the first day and it was
- it's like I'm solid but like I can't
[Music]
son foster why she's a delight she lies
a lot probably this guy's probably yeah
yes
dirty dog things are you so you're a
dirty dog roses definitely yeah you
haven't seen me even happen Molly oh
yeah I'm well yeah more than anyone else
my own I'm pretty wild I'm I go down
pool slides I go down I go ahead Miriam
yes Miriam cuz I'm sloppy and messy
never put together I know never to make
jewelry I don't wear any jewelry I hate
it and so that's not like Diana trout
Hillary job Hilary Duff yeah
this one so Molly and I became partners
in a book club just the two of us and
then she read the book in one day and I
was like that's not how the book club
works
I don't two kids right I I'm the one
that reads on set the most because
that's the only time that I have to read
Debbie that day never I'm the first time
soon
yeah for sure oh yeah all sorts of
triangles and shoes yeah no it's not
caught it's like he's like ah be
comfortable in that triangle I say me go
oh yeah doesn't consider it called
wrangle sudden I think the way to Sutton
Foster's heart is a nice cup of coffee
and some peanut butter crackers we take
breaks from craft services to go shoot
this one I think Nico yeah you never
shoot with me yeah that's true yeah like
with people that he shoots with me yeah
nobody know me nobody cares
no nobody in this room I've learned from
my teenagers okay well there's that
Miriam was in the conference room with
Hillary and Hillary got this she said oh
my god I'm getting all these messages
from my gram and and Miriam goes oh my
god your grandmother that's so sweet
so that's where we're at that is
probably Hillary yeah no I'm sorry gave
us the four of us no actually Molly oh
yeah I know is that you always have
something to say to you like I don't
know what this eye shadow yeah I never
knowing you're looking definitely I'm
hard time deciding like what color area
takes a long time
yeah
like I don't know what I'm gonna be sort
of pillow the killer I feel like I feel
like to get Diane yeah me to look like
Diana proudest it's a lot - yeah a lot
of people I don't like being in hair and
makeup not happy with the hair that's
right you got the hair me Nico do you I
love I just love to dream
you remember my tired I just go to sleep
just like a dream this place you know I
mean ninety-seven children just go in
the morning
depends on who's asking
he'll gives great relationship advice
you know yeah you do - I do you want
wasn't roxanna's we talked to him if
you're a good boy good boy
I say Nico just because he actually has
a Lancaster is it book about it yeah I
don't want advice on my relationship
oh it's here yes but what sort of a sort
of a bit of a cycle sort of a bit of it
do it I might do a little sing together
sudden foster sudden a Miriam yeah you
think that's enough I think
you're very legit impressions but I
haven't do you do impressions of us no
never
so I play Miriam should we start right
now yeah okay
look at me I'm good you're like this I
know my whole body vibrate like a
chihuahua
[Music]